vamos a hablar de la polarización de la
luz y nosotros sabemos que es la luz son
ondas electromagnéticas están compuestas
de campos electromagnéticos como los que
estoy dibujando aquí
éstos se encuentran verticalmente y este
es el campo eléctrico de esta onda de
luz pero sabemos que esto no es
suficiente sabemos que un campo
eléctrico por sí solo no se puede
sostener necesita de un campo magnético
que esté cambiando estos campos
magnéticos van a estar cambiando y van a
ser perpendiculares al campo eléctrico
voy a tratar de dibujarlo aquí aunque no
es tan fácil dibujarlo en un espacio
bidimensional va más o menos así y el
campo magnético es perpendicular al
campo eléctrico
pero si trato de dibujar ambos campos al
mismo tiempo se me va a saturar mi
pantalla así que solo voy a observar el
campo eléctrico aunque yo sé que existe
el campo magnético y normalmente es
suficiente conocer la dirección del
campo eléctrico para deducir lo demás
así que nos vamos a enfocar en el campo
eléctrico que significa la polarización
bueno imaginen que si esta luz está
siendo dirigida hacia nuestro ojo oa lo
mejor algún detector que es lo que vamos
a ver que veremos en el caso de tener
aquí una polarización bueno vamos a
dibujar un par de ejes aquí arriba
así
y así y esta línea este eje está justo
aquí en el centro y esto va directo
hacia nuestro estamos observando
directamente a esta línea y esto que va
de arriba a abajo aquí lo veremos de
arriba a abajo y de lado a lado en la
dirección donde tengo mi campo magnético
lo veríamos así en este caso lo que mi
ojo va a observar son aquellos campos
eléctricos que van arriba o hacia abajo
solo aquellos que van hacia arriba o
hacia abajo pueden ser de diferente
tamaño pero si yo puedo solamente ver
aquellos campos eléctricos que vayan
arriba o abajo entonces voy a tener una
polarización tendré luz polarizada y la
luz polarizada es aquella cuyo campo
eléctrico solo está oscilando en una
dirección en este caso de arriba a abajo
que sería la dirección vertical o podría
estar polarizada horizontalmente o
diagonalmente aquí no importa
tener la luz polarizada en cualquier
dirección a lo mejor tengo un rayo de
luz cuyo campo eléctrico está diagonal y
solo lo puedo ver en esta dirección aquí
en este caso también tendremos un rayo
de luz polarizada estos dos son casos de
polarización de la luz ya que solamente
tengo una dirección en la que está
oscilando la luz y ustedes pueden pensar
caray pues en qué momento puedo
encontrarme luz que no esté polarizada
bueno de hecho la luz que viene
directamente del sol no está polarizada
también la luz que podemos ver de
aquellos focos viejitos incandescentes
que se calentaban al encenderse también
la luz que sale de aquí no es polarizada
puede ir en cualquier dirección
al mismo tiempo y sobreponiéndose entre
sí si dibujáramos el campo eléctrico de
un foco incandescente veríamos algo como
esto una parte de su campo magnético
iría por acá otra en otro momento idea
por acá otra hacia acá
en todas las direcciones posibles
también tendríamos luz que llega
directamente hacia nosotros tendríamos
que sumar todas estas para obtener el
total e incluso quizás no sea la misma
cantidad pero lo que quiero decir aquí
es que nosotros en un momento dado no
sabemos cuál va a ser la dirección que
traiga el campo eléctrico de este rayo
de luz puede llegar de cualquier
dirección así que esto no es polarizado
no es
polarizado
esto de aquí
en algún momento del tiempo el campo
eléctrico puede estar apuntando para acá
o puede estar apuntando para acá o por
acá es aleatorio en cambio estos dos y
son polarizados como puedo yo polarizar
luz que no viene polarizada de la fuente
pues muy sencillo vamos a usar
unos dispositivos conocidos como
polarizador es
estos elementos sólo me van a dejar
pasar la luz que está en cierta
dirección por ejemplo a lo mejor este
solo me deja pasar aquella luz que está
en esta dirección vertical este
polarizador está hecho de un material
que solo me permite pasar aquella luz
que coincide con esta orientación esto
es un polarizador polarizador no son
caros normalmente están hechos de
plástico y tienen una configuración que
me permite pasar solamente aquella luz
que coincide con esta orientación y me
bloquea todo lo demás que no cumple con
esto cualquier rayo de luz que quiera
pasar por aquí y que no esté polarizado
verticalmente se va a bloquear lo que
significa que si yo tomo este
polarizador y lo pongo al frente de esta
luz entre mi ojo y el foco lo que yo
veré será solamente a aquellos rayos de
luz que tienen esta dirección todos los
demás se van a bloquear
podemos rotar esto e imaginarnos que
tenemos un polarizador que solo va a
dejar pasar la luz que está polarizada
horizontalmente de esta manera
solo dejara pasar a la luz que está en
esta dirección por lo que nosotros
solamente veremos
estos rayos de luz que tienen esta
dirección o podemos colocarlo en
cualquier ángulo que nosotros querramos
y sólo va a dejar pasar a aquellos rayos
de luz que coinciden con el ángulo que
tenemos aquí así que una vez que usamos
estos dispositivos vamos a tener luz que
está polarizada luz que solo tiene una
orientación esto es la polarización pero
porque nos interesa vamos a quitar esto
por un momento ustedes han escuchado
hablar de los lentes polarizados
imagínense que se encuentran cerca del
agua o del hielo o de la nieve o de
cualquier material que refleje la luz
imaginamos que se encuentran en el
exterior y está el sol muy brillante es
un día muy bonito pero el problema aquí
es que se van a deslumbrar si esa
superficie es reflejante y llega la luz
del sol aquí les va a dar directo en el
rostro y los va a deslumbrar
que esta luz no es polarizada por lo que
va a estar en todas las direcciones
pero algunos rayos de luz van a tener
esta dirección que va a llegar aquí y
les va a dar en el rostro tenemos luz
ambiental que viene de las nubes o de lo
que nos rodea pero esta luz que llega
aquí directamente es bastante dura si
nos llega directamente al rostro nos va
a molestar va a evitar que podamos ver
nos va a deslumbrar no nos va a dejar
ver lo que nos rodea así que no queremos
que nos deslumbre no queremos
deslumbrarnos
qué podemos hacer aquí bueno resulta que
cuando la luz del sol se refleja en una
superficie aunque ya sabemos que la luz
del sol no es polarizada una vez que
esta luz se refleja se va a polarizar o
al menos se va a polarizar parcialmente
imaginemos que tenemos esta superficie y
esta luz va a llegar de aquí sin
polarizar se va a ir en cualquier
dirección que se le ocurra nuestro campo
eléctrico va a tener una dirección
aleatoria y así es como viene la luz del
sol sin embargo una vez que se refleja
esta luz va a estar o va a tener cierta
polarización y esta polarización depende
del plano o del ángulo que tenga esta
superficie en la que se refleja debido a
que esta superficie está horizontal una
vez que llega esta luz y se refleja aquí
el reflejo va a estar polarizado en su
mayor parte horizontalmente estos
componentes
horizontales del campo eléctrico se van
a encontrar más presentes que los
componentes que tengan otra dirección
quizás no completamente aunque hay veces
en que la luz se polariza totalmente
pero no es necesario puede ser una
polarización parcial y esto es genial
porque yo ya sé que puedo hacer voy a
colocarme frente a mis ojos unos
polarizador es que bloqueen los rayos de
luz con polarización horizontal aquí voy
a dibujar mis lentes polarizados y ya
que quiero deshacerme de lo que me
deslumbra como los voy a configurar voy
a asegurarme que mis lentes polarizados
sólo dejen pasar la luz con la
orientación vertical y bloqueen todo lo
demás de esta manera todo esto que me
puede deslumbrar se bloquea ya que la
mayor parte de esto tiene una
orientación horizontal y no vertical
esto es algo bueno que hace la
polarización por nosotros por lo que es
bueno conocerla esto también le gusta a
los pescadores ya que ellos quieren
observar lo que se encuentra por debajo
del agua no el brillo que se refleja en
ella ellos quieren ver a los peces que
se encuentran por acá queremos ver la
luz que viene del pez y no este brillo
tremendo que viene del sol así que los
lentes polarizados son muy buenos pero
también podemos hacerles trucos a
nuestros ojos
por ejemplo en estos lentes puede ser
que en un ojo se tenga una polarización
vertical y en el otro ojo una
polarización horizontal
y ustedes me pueden decir oye esto no
tiene sentido este ojo va a recibir
mucho brillo bueno estos lentes no son
para usar en el exterior pero este truco
lo podemos hacer cuando vamos a ver
películas al cine la razón por la que
vemos en tres dimensiones es porque
nuestros ojos están separados cierta
distancia y cada uno recibe una imagen
ligeramente diferente y es por eso que
podemos ver en tres dimensiones podemos
simular algo parecido con estos lentes
si tenemos este tipo de polarización en
la pantalla del cine cierta luz puede
salir con una polarización y otra luz
puede salir con otra polarización y con
esto podemos enviar dos imágenes
diferentes a cada uno de nuestros ojos
si nos quitamos los lentes esto se va a
ver muy feo va a estar todo borroso y no
se va a ver bien ya que tendremos estas
dos imágenes diferentes que se van a
trasladar cuando ustedes ven una
película de tres dimensiones y se quitan
los lentes en el cine la imagen se ve
muy fea
ya que nuestros dos ojos reciben estas
dos imágenes pero cuando nos ponemos los
lentes este ojo sólo va a tener aquella
luz que tiene esta orientación y este
otro ojo va a haber solamente aquella
luz que tiene esta otra orientación y de
esta manera tendremos una imagen
tridimensional esto es bastante útil
para diversas cosas permítanme regresar
a esto aquí tenemos esta polarización
vertical y se le llama polarización
lineal lo mismo en este caso aquí
también tenemos polarización lineal
porque la luz pasa solamente en una
dirección lineal en este caso arriba
abajo o en diagonal estas dos son
lineales pero podemos tener polarización
circular así que regresamos aquí y
tenemos nuestro campo eléctrico que
apunta hacia arriba así
pero imaginemos que tenemos otro rayo de
luz que no tiene su polarización en este
sentido ahora nuestro rayo de luz va a
estar más o menos
este no es el campo magnético de esta
onda sino un rayo de luz completamente
diferente que también tiene su propio
campo magnético independiente de este
otro rayo aquí lo que sucede es que
tendremos un campo eléctrico que va en
esta dirección
y otro campo eléctrico que va en esta
dirección que es lo que va a observar
nuestro ojo si está nuestro ojo por aquí
dibujamos nuestros ejes por acá cuando
esta parte del rayo de luz llegue a mi
ojo este componente yo lo voy a ver
así esto es este campo eléctrico y este
componente de este otro campo eléctrico
lo voy a ver
por lo que el campo eléctrico total va a
lucir así puedo usar aquí el teorema de
pitágoras para encontrar el valor exacto
de esto pero por el momento solo nos
interesa la dirección luego esta luz
llega aquí donde tenemos los dos campos
eléctricos en cero por lo que aquí solo
veremos esto y ahora llegamos aquí y lo
que vamos a ver es esto apuntando hacia
la derecha y en este mismo punto el
campo eléctrico rojo va a estar
apuntando hacia abajo así que esto
también lo tengo aquí y en este punto el
campo eléctrico total va a estar por acá
y voy a tener esto que se repite una y
otra vez aquí voy a tener luz polarizada
diagonalmente y me pueden decir bueno y
esto para qué me sirve no hay nada nuevo
aquí para que envió dos rayos de luz de
manera que me den esta polarización
diagonal pudimos haber mandado solamente
un rayo de luz que ya tuviera su
polarización diagonal y con
obtener esto que queremos la razón es
que si yo desfase esta onda morada unos
90 grados o pie entre dos de fase aquí
algo mágico sucede voy a tener esto así
ahora no sólo vamos a tener una
polarización diagonal vamos a quitar
esto de aquí dibujamos de nuevo nuestros
ejes
aquí está nuestro campo eléctrico de
esta onda
y comenzamos con este campo eléctrico en
rojo que lo veríamos así el campo
eléctrico rosa está en cero así que
solamente vería esto solo tendría esto
de manera que mi campo eléctrico total
lo voy a dibujar aquí estaría así en
verde tendremos nuestro campo eléctrico
total luego paso por acá y veremos que
una parte de este campo eléctrico apunta
hacia arriba pero también tendremos una
parte de este campo eléctrico rosa que
apunta hacia acá por lo que tendré un
campo eléctrico total que apunta hacia
acá ahora llego a este punto en donde
tengo todo el campo eléctrico de la onda
rosa y nada del campo eléctrico de la
roja por lo que mi campo eléctrico total
va a apuntar hacia acá que es lo que
está pasando
esta polarización de la luz solamente
con este desplazamiento de 90 grados lo
que yo observo con mi ojo es que esta
polarización va a ir cambiando va a ir
rotando de esta manera
voy a ver que la polarización se mueve
en este patrón circular que estoy
mostrando más o menos aquí
y es debido a esto que lo llamamos
polarización
circular
polarización circular
este es otro tipo de polarización en
donde el ángulo de polarización va a
rotar suavemente conforme se mueven
estos rayos de luz aunque bueno
realmente conforme está esta
distribución primero vamos a recibir el
rayo de luz que se encuentra más cerca
de nosotros luego será el que sigue y el
que sigue irá así y así y es por eso que
veremos la polarización en sentido
horario y ustedes se pueden preguntar
bueno para que nos interesa la
polarización circular puedes hacer un
momento no les dije las cosas
exactamente como son
lo que normalmente ocurre en las salas
de cine es que no tenemos una
polarización vertical y horizontal ya
que si nosotros la dejáramos ligeramente
nuestra cabeza ya no podríamos recibir
la imagen tal cual con tantito que la
dejáramos nuestra cabeza este ojo ya no
va a recibir la imagen completa sino un
poquito de ambas imágenes lo mismo con
este ojo de manera que veríamos las
cosas borrosas en este caso nuestra
cabeza tendría que estar perfectamente
nivelada y tendría que estar así durante
todo el tiempo que dure la película lo
que podría ser algo incómodo por lo que
vamos a tener lentes polarizados
circularmente uno de los lentes va a
tener la polarización en esta dirección
y el otro de los lentes tendrá la
polarización en la otra dirección de
esta manera no importa si la veamos un
poco nuestra cabeza ya que esta es una
polarización en sentido horario y este
es en sentido antihorario así que es
tener la polarización circular en las
películas de tres dimensiones
que esto sea más fácil veremos bien
nuestra película en tres dimensiones
aunque nuestra cabeza se la dé un poco